ça la menace russe les etats-unis
montrent leurs muscles washington met en
alerte huit mille cinq cents soldats
prêts à renforcer l'otan en cas
d'invasion russes en territoire
ukrainien une annonce faite à l'issue
d'une réunion d'urgence entre joe biden
et les alliés occidentaux monsieur c'est
très important j'ai eu un très bon
entretien en totale unanimité avec les
dirigeants européens
l'alliance a déjà 4000 militaires sur le
terrain principalement en pologne et
dans les pays baltes à cela s'ajoutent
des chars d'assaut et des unités de
défense aérienne
ces déploiements sont proportionnée et
adaptée à nos engagements internationaux
il renforce la sécurité de l'europe pour
nous tous
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs semaines la russie a
déployé quelques cent mille soldats à
proximité de la frontière ukrainienne
mais rejette toute intention belliqueuse
et accusent l'occident d'attiser les
tensions dans ce contexte une partie du
personnel diplomatique américain et
britannique est invité à quitter
l'ukraine une décision trop hâtive selon
bruxelles faut rester tranquille en
faisant ce qu'il faut faire mais en
évitant de d'une crise de nerf à
quelques kilomètres du front cette
tension est devenu le quotidien des
ukrainiens à donetsk bastions des
séparatistes pro-russes la jeunesse
redoute que le conflit ne s'envenime
c'est toujours dangereux ici c'est
effrayant parce que pendant toute mon
enfance à donetsk j'ai entendu la guerre
les bombardements les chars rouler dans
la ville je suis déjà fatigués par cette
situation le conflit n'a pas de sens on
ne sait même pas pourquoi la guerre
continue c'est comme une sorte de
conflit qui suit son cours côté français
emmanuel macron veut se poser en
médiateur
un entretien avec vladimir poutine doit
avoir lieu dans les prochains jours pour
tenter une nouvelle fois d'apaiser les
tensions